RACHEL AMERA: Hi.
I'm Rachel Amera, and I'm based
in the San Francisco office
usually.
I'm part of the gPause Program.
I'm a volunteer to help bring
in speakers and coordinate that.
And today I'm really excited
to bring in Doctor Leslie Carr.
Doctor Carr is here
to talk about why
being present in
any relationship
is vital for
emotional well-being
and emotional health.
So this is going to be a
great talk for all of us.
We all have
relationships, I think.
Whether it's at work, whether
it's in your personal life,
with your family,
relationships are everywhere.
It's really what
is the groundwork
for a lot of what we do.
So today, we're going
to talk about how
we can improve any of those,
which is I think not only
important for work,
but in any case
and in any aspect of our lives.
Again, we'll look at things
like the interpersonal science
behind that, too.
So that's part of what
we want to bring out
in the gPause
Program, is what is
going on in the world
of learning more
about this from a
scientific standpoint,
a neuroscience standpoint.
So Doctor Carr is going
to talk about that, too.
And then we're
going to all learn
how to be better listeners.
We're going to learn how
we can tune in, literally,
to other people so
we can feel more
supported by our own presence.
And I think that is a skill
that I know I could use and get
more of, and I think all of us
would like to learn more of.
Doctor Carr is a licensed
clinical psychologist
who works out of San
Francisco, and she's
a published author for
MindBodyGreen, the newsletter
in "The Huffington Post."
So without further ado,
I will introduce Leslie.
Thank you for coming today.
[APPLAUSE]
LESLIE CARR: Thank you so
much, Rachel, and thank you
all for being here.
Since we're here today to
talk about mindfulness,
I just want to begin by
allowing us to take a moment
to just shift gears.
Perhaps we can all
just take a minute
to forget about anything that
we were doing before we came
into this room, just give
ourselves permission to not
think about anything
that you're going
to do when you leave here.
Take a minute to just feel
your butt in your seats.
Since I'm standing,
I'm just going
to take a minute to really
feel my feet on the ground.
And perhaps you can
just give yourself
a moment to allow
your eyes to fall
on anything that is in your
natural field of vision.
And just take a
moment and look at it.
Take a deep breath.
For those of you who don't
know what mindfulness
is-- I know a couple of you
raised your hands before saying
that this is unfamiliar
territory for you-- when we
talk about mindfulness,
this is really
what we're talking about.
We're really just talking
about present moment awareness.
It's a certain type
of psychological state
that involves thinking less
about the past and the future
and more about what's actually
happening right in front of us.
Unfortunately, it
sounds so simple,
but I think in reality, in the
Western world, very few of us
spend much time here.
And what I'm going to be
talking to you about today
is how we can use that type
of psychological attention
in our relationships to be
more present with one another
and to make us better listeners.
And it is absolutely
not an exaggeration
to say that using
these skills actually
has a measurable impact
on our mental health,
and on the mental
health of the people
that we are having
conversations with,
existing in relationship
with, and that kind of stuff.
So without further ado, I want
to take a moment just before we
really dig in here to
speak for just a minute
about mental health in general.
Because I'm not
here today to talk
about mental
illness-- if anything,
I'm actually here to
talk about mental health,
but these are very
interrelated concepts.
And I think it's
important to kind of start
by defining our terms a little
bit and just making sure
that the train is moving
in the right direction.
So maybe I can just
start with a question.
Raise your hand if you
think of mental illness
as being created by chemical
imbalances in the brain,
if you think of it as
being a largely genetic
or biochemical experience.
Perhaps you could-- OK.
So that gives me certainly
a frame of reference.
I'd say probably 50% of you
roughly raised your hands.
And I'm not surprised by that.
If anything, I'm
sort of surprised
that more people didn't raise
their hands, just because that
is something that-- it's an idea
that exists in popular culture
absolutely.
I think that we are
really steeped in the idea
that our mental health
experiences are created largely
by genes and biochemistry.
And I'm not here to say
that that isn't the case.
I'm not here to say
that genes don't
matter, that our
biochemistry doesn't matter.
But I think that there is this
other piece of the puzzle that
doesn't get nearly as
much air time, which
is the role that things like
our relationships and our life
experiences play in our mental
health or mental illness.
We have traumatic
experiences, we respond
to those traumatic experiences.
Believe it or not,
we have experiences
that are entirely mundane, and
we learn from those experiences
and take them forward with us.
So I guess what I want
to make clear right now
is just that it's not that
genes and biochemistry doesn't
matter, but what I'm going to
be talking to you about today
primarily is this other piece,
the piece of our relationships
and the experiences
that we have.
And just to drive this
point home, in case
this is confusing for
anybody, something
that I just want to
really make clear
is that because of this thing
that we call epigenetics,
we have to sort of
recognize that even
if we possess the
gene for something,
or even if there's a biological
proclivity toward something,
our life experiences, whether
we're exposed to toxins,
whether we have good
relationships in our lives,
these things have the power
to quite literally turn genes
on and off and affect
their expression.
So I think this is
really important stuff
that we're talking about.
There's actually amazing
cutting-edge research
going on right now showing
that people who are chronically
lonely are more likely
to be aggressive,
and it quite literally is
turning genes on and off
that are impacting how people
are behaving in the world based
on just the experience of
being chronically lonely.
So I am going to zip you through
about 70 years of research
in my field and tell
you a couple of stories
that I think will help
to explain the way I
look at some of this stuff.
And perhaps we'll
take it from there.
The first story that I want to
tell you takes us back to 1945.
We were starting to
realize-- at the time,
people were starting
to realize--
that we had a really
big problem happening
in our orphanage system,
because orphans were dying
at a really alarming rate,
a rate that greatly outpaced
children in the
general population.
And at first, naturally
they thought that this
was an immunity issue.
The concern was
really just that there
were so many babies and nurses
and people in a relatively
contained environment that it
was creating a situation where
just germs were really thriving
and the kids were getting sick.
The problem was that
their reaction to this
was to kind of batten
down the hatches
and to do things like
touch the children less.
They actually went so
far in some orphanages
to put up sheets
between the cribs
so that the kids were
totally and completely
separated from one another,
separated from their caregivers
and that kind of stuff.
And their nurses were
told to touch them
as little as possible,
to touch them
just enough to change their
diapers and hand them a bottle.
And the problem
actually got worse.
It became even more extreme.
So 1945 again, a
psychoanalyst and physician
named Rene Spitz decided that he
wanted to take a look at this.
And he created a bit of a--
we actually wouldn't really
call it an experiment
today, but he
wanted to investigate
the situation
by comparing the children
in these orphanages
to children who were being
raised in the prison system
by their mothers because their
mothers had been incarcerated.
Because there
obviously were a lot
of similarities between
these environments,
just a lot of people in a small
space, less access to things
like natural air and
that kind of stuff.
And in the time that
Doctor Spitz was reviewing
this information,
37% of the kids
in the orphanage-- it was an
American orphanage that he was
looking at-- 37% of the kids
between the ages of zero
and three died, and none of
the children in the prison
population died.
And when they looked at the
data, what they realized
was that the only difference
between these babies
was the fact that the ones who
were being raised in prison
were being raised
by their mothers,
there were people around, and
the ones in the orphanages
were not really having any
contact with people at all.
And it's definitely worth noting
that not only were the kids
dying, but for the kids
who were not dying,
they were really
not doing very well.
They were psychiatrically
They had lower IQs than kids
in the general population
or the kids in the prison did.
Eventually they were developing
physical disabilities,
because they weren't able
to get around and crawl.
And one of the reasons
why this research was
so groundbreaking at the
time that it came out
was because mothers in
the 1940s were actually
told that they shouldn't
touch their children too much
because it might spoil them.
And this was one of the first
things that made people really
question that advice,
which brings us
to the next major
piece of research that
came on its heels.
It was a psychologist
named Harry Harlow
who was working out of the
University of Wisconsin
at the time.
And inspired by
Spitz's research,
he wanted to conduct
some research
with rhesus monkeys
in environments
where we could sort of control
the environment a little bit
more.
And some of you might
be familiar with this,
because this is a little
bit sort of psych 101
kind of stuff.
But what he wanted to do,
he did a series of studies.
And they began with what
has been termed the cloth
mother versus the wire mother.
He created two environments
for these monkeys.
He gave them the option of
either a wire mother that
provided food but no additional
comfort or anything like that,
and then the cloth
mother that was made out
of terry cloth that was
physically comfortable
but didn't provide any
nourishment of any kind.
And his theory-- I guess what
he was looking to investigate
is the theory at the time
was that children really only
became attached to their parents
because that's where they got
food and that kind of stuff.
So his theory was basically that
if these monkeys were the way
he thought they would be,
that they wouldn't express
much interest in the
terry cloth mother,
because it didn't
actually provide them
with any nourishment
or any food.
Now it's probably
not that shocking,
but actually the monkeys
ended up spending
like 90% of their days kind of
hanging out on this terry cloth
mother, and then just running
over to the wire mother
to get food periodically
whenever they were hungry.
And perhaps even Harlow
himself was not that surprised,
because terry cloth is a lot
more comfortable than wire.
So I guess he felt the need
to take things a little bit
further.
And he designed
another study that
made things just a
little bit more extreme
where he would do things
like scare the monkeys
and then see what would happen
once they had been hanging out
on the cloth mother for awhile
and had become ostensibly
sort of attached to it.
What would happen if you
took them out into the room,
scared them.
What they do?
And monkeys are often used--
rhesus monkeys particularly--
in psychological
research, because they
display some characteristics
that are similar to humans.
And the monkeys
did something that
is typical of what
humans would do,
and they would run back
to the cloth mother
because-- it's sort
of in the same way
that you would
see with children,
that if a kid is scared
it would run to its mom.
The rhesus monkeys would do
that with the cloth mother.
Now unfortunately,
Harry Harlow did not
like rhesus monkeys very much.
He actually went on the
record as saying that.
So some of his research starts
to get a little bit more
and more disturbing.
And if you're an
animal lover like me,
you're not going to want to
hear what I have to say next.
But in order to push the
limits, what he started to do
was he would take
the rhesus monkeys
and put them in isolation
chambers for three months, six
months, nine months, a
year, sometimes even longer
than that.
And the amounts of time
actually really stop mattering,
because the point
is that by the time
a rhesus monkey has
been put in an isolation
chamber for 12 months, it
emerges really not the same.
The monkeys, by
the time they were
in these chambers for a year,
were behaving really bizarrely.
They would rock
themselves back and forth,
stare off into the distance,
and that kind of thing.
And if you're wondering why
I'm telling you these stories,
it's because I'm trying to
drive us towards a point.
And that point is what
was happening here?
I don't know if anyone
has any theories about why
these babies in their
orphanages would be dying,
or why the monkeys, when
put in isolation chambers,
would emerge so
psychologically distressed.
But what we now
know, 70 years later,
is that what the monkeys and the
babies were lacking was this.
The photos and the
images behind me
are showing what we call
in my field attunement.
It's the technical term that we
have started to use in my field
for this process, which is
a very delicate dance that
happens between babies
and their caregivers.
And if you've ever
known an infant,
you have probably
participated in this yourself.
It turns out that even just
these micro-moments that
happen in facial expression and
the relationship that develops
between a child
and its caregiver
provides an enormous
psychological function
in helping us to
develop brains that
are capable of things like
psychological organization.
Babies between about
zero and three months
aren't really
capable of this yet.
It's something that's
commonly referred
to as the fourth trimester.
But after about three
months, once you
get to three months,
six months, nine months,
you start to see this
dance quite a bit more.
And what you start
to see, or what
we have come to realize
is true about infants,
is that this is
literally how babies
start to realize that they're
separate beings psychologically
from their caregivers and
from the people around them.
There's this complex
dance that happens
in facial expression that plays
a really important role in who
we are and who we come to be.
And it's very closely
related to this other thing
that we refer to as attachment.
Attachment in psychology
and in our well-being
is a really big
and vast concept.
This is where a lot of
research takes place today.
But as you can see in this
sort of graph behind me,
the basic concept
behind attachment
is it has to do with what we
consider to be sort of signal
response communication.
The idea that a baby has
a need, like its diaper
needs to be changed,
so it cries,
it signals to its
caregiver that it has
a need that needs to be met.
And in an ideal world, the
caregiver meets that need.
And over time, a sense
of trust and safety
develops not just between
that baby and its caregiver,
but between that child
and the world itself.
There's this idea that I have a
need and that need can be met.
And what we know
now, as a result
of Harlow's research
and Spitz's research,
is that it's not just
food and diaper changes
that babies need, but
it's actually this.
It's what we call attunement.
And even though this is
vitally important for babies,
it doesn't stop being
important for adults.
If you've ever had that
experience of just feeling
really connected to
somebody, feeling
like you're having a
conversation with someone
and they're just
really getting you
and you're totally
on the same page,
there is a
neurotransmitter that is
responsible for making
you feel that way,
and it's called oxytocin.
Oxytocin has been called
the bonding hormone.
And it's a neuropeptide
that flows whenever
we're feeling really close and
connected to somebody, if we're
having a really
good conversation.
For women, we tend to get
extra big bursts of it
when women are having
orgasms, or are
in labor, which contributes
to that feeling of feeling
super bonded to your baby
in that moment after birth.
And what you can sort
of see in these images
is people just having happy
conversations with each other,
face to face, and having
a lot of oxytocin flowing.
And I don't think that
it will surprise you
when I say that
instead of seeing this
these days, what we often
see more of is this.
And I am not
anti-technology, believe me.
I am not standing
before you as a Luddite.
I love technology.
As a psychotherapist, a lot of
the people that I work with I
see via Skype.
I'm active on social media.
I am not an
anti-technology person.
But I don't think
I'm alone when I
say that as we start to
see more and more of this,
that I don't think I'm
the only person who
is starting to become a
little bit distressed by it
and is maybe starting
to perceive some
of the downsides of just how
much exposure to technology
we've been engaging in lately.
And I think that this,
headlines like this,
are a pretty good
example of that.
I think these are the kinds
of questions that we're
asking ourselves more and more.
And neurobiologically-speaking,
it's
worth noting that part of
the reason why technology
is so satisfying to
use is because we get
these little dopamine bursts.
From a neurotransmitter
perspective,
it's the same thing,
it's the same sort
of neurobiological
reward that we
get when we're playing the
slots or doing cocaine.
It's extremely pleasurable
to get a dose of dopamine.
But what we don't get when we're
using technology is oxytocin.
We don't have the same bond
that we feel with each other
when we're having a face to
face conversation, or even
a conversation over the phone
when we're using technology.
And one of the dilemmas
that we have here,
and this is where I feel
like what we're talking about
is really important,
is that it's
starting to become
more and more extreme.
This article right
here, which came out
in April of this year
in The New York Times,
talks about some really
disturbing research
where they're recognizing that
little kids are spending so
much time looking
at screens that they
are less able to
interpret nonverbal cues.
They're less able to
read facial expressions.
Their social skills
are quite literally
suffering as a result.
So most of the
people in this room
are old enough to probably
remember a time when we weren't
using technology so much.
I think even we are experiencing
the ramifications of spending
so much time using technology.
I think it's really
hard to even imagine
what is happening to kids
who are three years old right
now, six years
old, 10 years old,
with so much exposure
to technology.
So what is the point
of all of this?
The point in my
mind is really just
that our human
relationships really
matter, perhaps more
so than a lot of us
really give them credit for.
I'm going to spend the rest of
this talk focusing primarily
on listening, talking
about what it really
means to be a good listener.
And something that
I just want to make
clear is that I think in
adult to adult communication,
really listening
to each other is
sort of the updated version
of those attunement photos
that I was showing to you.
How we listen to
each other is how
we make our presence
felt by the people
that we're in
relationships with.
And I want to just sort of
transition and shift gears
here a little bit
by reading a quote.
I'll go ahead and
read this to you.
This is one of my
favorite psychologists,
someone named Carl Rogers.
He has so many beautiful
quotes, and this
is one of my favorites.
Sensitive, active listening is
exceedingly rare in our lives.
We think we listen,
but very rarely
do we listen with real
understanding or true empathy.
Yet listening of this
very special kind
is one of the most potent
forces for change that I know.
Now something that is very
cool about Carl Rogers
is that he is the originator
of something that has
been termed active listening.
It's actually sort
of a code of skills.
And it's something that's been
tremendously influential for me
in my work as a psychotherapist,
but it also provides
the backbone of what the
FBI teaches its hostage
negotiators, which
I actually think
is a really
fascinating data point.
The FBI created a course in
1979 called the National Crisis
Negotiation course.
And since 1979, it has been
the number one course worldwide
for training people in
high-stakes crisis negotiation.
It's what they use to
train their own FBI hostage
negotiators, but
it's also anyone
in the world who needs
to learn about this
for the sake of
diplomacy or anything
like that can come and
attend this course.
And the data is
really outstanding.
It has successfully contributed
in tens of thousands
of lives saved as a result of
the success of this program.
And all they train people
in is active listening.
The FBI actually tells
its hostage negotiators
to not try to troubleshoot the
crisis, or to try to convince,
let's say, a hostage-taker to
do something in particular.
They quite literally just
train them in listening,
rapport-building,
helping a hostage-taker
to feel heard and understood.
And it actually works.
It's effective at getting people
to just kind of soften and let
go of their agenda.
So we'll spend the rest
of this talk speaking
a little bit about active
listening and what it entails.
To begin, we'll just say that
active listening includes
sincerely trying to understand
another person's opinion
or subjective experience,
respecting the other person's
feelings and experience,
expressing empathy,
and building rapport.
And what it doesn't include
is being judgmental--
which is sometimes
easier said than done,
but it's a goal-- rushing the
process or the conversation,
problem-solving, or patronizing.
And I have, over the years,
isolated six specific steps
that I think are
particularly important when
we talk about listening and when
we talk about active listening.
And just one by one I'm going
to bring you through them.
And afterwards, we'll
transition into the Q&A.
So if you have any questions, we
will have more than enough time
for that.
But the first one is
making eye contact.
And something that I
want to bring you back to
is just at the
top of this speech
when I was just kind of inviting
us to really get present
and just to focus
on what was actually
happening in the moment.
This is really our
first opportunity,
I think, when we're having
a conversation with somebody
to really bring things back
to a place of mindfulness,
and to remind ourselves that we
don't have to be multitasking
and we can really
be paying attention
to what they're saying.
I think making really good
eye contact-- the point is not
necessarily for it to be
creepy, you don't want
to be staring at somebody--
but by making really good eye
contact, you can allow
yourself to just kind of forget
about other things.
You can really focus
on making eye contact
and stop thinking about
what you need to do,
your to-do list,
what you're going
to do after you're done with
the conversation, whatever
the case may be.
And part and parcel
of that is what
we call mirroring an
effective facial expression.
This is also a little bit
like those attunement photos.
It's worth noting
that this is something
that people do naturally,
so it's actually
not something that we have
to work super hard at.
But a really good example
of where this is important
is just that if
you were telling me
something that was really sad
or something that really bummed
you out and I was looking
at you with a really
big smile on my face, that
would be super creepy, right.
So the goal is really
just to kind of get
in tune with the moment.
And if you're talking to
somebody who's telling you
about something that makes
them feel sad, just kind of,
you know, take in that
vibe a little bit,
kind of going with it.
This is a really
big, important one.
Don't think about what
you're going to say next.
I think this is particularly
rife in our culture
because people are so afraid
of a moment of silence
I think in a lot of ways that
it's really common for people
to spend the time that
someone else is speaking
thinking about how
they're going to respond.
And what I want to
suggest to everyone here
is that it's actually OK if
there's a moment of silence.
If somebody gets to the end
of their sentence and you
have to think for a
moment before you--
as you collect your
thoughts and say
whatever you're going to say.
The funny thing is that I find
that it's actually very rare
that very much time goes by.
Usually we're able to process
things really quickly.
But allowing somebody to
fully complete their thought
and to get to the end of their
sentence before we jump in
and respond is actually
a very crucial piece
of listening and having
a good conversation.
So this next one is easier
said than done, but also very
important.
Sincerely trying to
suspend judgment.
One of the things
that I value most
about my experience of
having become a psychologist
is really fully having the
opportunity to recognize
how much people's
perspectives vary from one
another, kind of going
back to what I was saying
in the beginning just
about how our life
experiences and
our relationships
play a really big role in our
mental health, mental illness,
that kind of thing.
It's actually really--
can be surprising to know
how much people's
perspectives on the world
are shaped as a result
of the experiences
that we've had in the past.
So I think just if we even
notice ourselves feeling
inclined to judge
another person,
it's a really important
and valuable time
to just take a step back and
to recognize that you think
whatever it is that you think
because of your own life
experiences.
Whoever it is that
you're talking to you
has lived through an
entirely different universe
of life experience.
And the goal in a
conversation is really
to seriously try to understand,
and you can't really
do that if you're
judging someone.
I mean if you were-- if
we kind of take it back
to the FBI hostage negotiation
situation for a moment,
it actually wouldn't really
be very effective conflict
resolution if the hostage
negotiators weren't sincerely
able to suspend judgment
and try to understand
what a hostage-taker
is motivated by.
What are they really motivated
by, what do they want here.
So trying as much as
possible to suspend judgment
is really important.
Asking clarifying questions.
This might sound a
little bit obvious,
but it's related to the
piece right before it.
If you don't understand,
then it really
is your job to just ask
questions until you understand.
And I think it
can be really good
for us to remember,
keep in mind,
that when we're
listening, there's
really no such thing as
asking too many questions.
If you're really
not understanding
what's bothering someone, just
ask more and more questions.
And finally-- this one is
really important, too--
just making
statements that prove
that you're paying attention.
I think one thing
that's a little bit
unfortunate about listening
is that just because we
are listening
doesn't necessarily
mean that the other
person is going
to feel like we're listening
or is going to feel heard.
And the goal is
truly to make sure
that the other
person feels heard.
So even if somebody's talking
all about how overwhelming they
are-- or how overwhelmed they
feel, they're complaining
they've got so much going
on, something as simple
as it sounds like you
feel really overwhelmed,
kind of distilling
it into something,
can be really helpful.
So again, I just want
to conclude today
by saying that I
think that everything
that we're here to
talk about today
is really important stuff.
Something that might be
interesting for a lot of you
guys to note is, I know this
stuff can be really confusing
to people, you know,
psychiatrists, psychologists,
that kind of thing.
Psychiatrists are
medical doctors.
They're the people that
write prescriptions.
As a psychologist, I don't
have prescription privileges.
Pretty much everything
that I do in my work
is related to the
conversations that I
have with people, my
ability to listen, to be
present with them,
to express empathy.
And it's not to say that
that's all that I do,
and I'm not suggesting that
anyone here go out and practice
psychotherapy without a license,
but I have years of experience
under my belt that have
shown me that it's actually
really surprising how much
better people can feel
in general when they have a
conversation with somebody
where they feel heard
and they feel understood
and they feel like that
person was able to be present
and to listen to them
without judgment.
And I have also
come to find over
the course of the
past couple years
that because there's sort of
a shortage of good listeners
in the world, I think that a
lot of times when people are
in the presence of someone who's
a good listener-- and I know I
have this feeling
all the time, if I
feel like I'm in the
presence of someone who's
a really good listener, it
feels super refreshing to me.
So I just want to
encourage everyone
to kind of take these
skills out on the road
and to be someone
that other people feel
is a refreshing
person to be around.
And maybe with that
in mind, we can just
turn it over to the Q&A.
AUDIENCE: So thanks
for coming today.
So the question I had
is how much are you,
let's say, like [INAUDIBLE] I
am in the typical situation,
like we are all on our phones.
So how much you are
explicit about it
and how much you are implicit,
and just to clarify should
I actively listen to my friends
and hope that will create
that atmosphere, or
people that I care about,
redefine rules of engagement.
I don't know if you have one.
That's what I mean by
explicit or implicit.
LESLIE CARR: So
just to make sure
that I understand
the question, I
take it it's basically
like how do you
kind of-- how do you
sort of cultivate
this kind of environment
with your friends, right.
Do you just lead
by example, do you
tell people to turn their
phones off, that kind of thing?
Yeah, I think it
really varies actually.
I mean I look at a
lot of this stuff
through the lens of just
really building awareness.
So I think you probably could
make different decisions based
on the environment that
you're in, how well you know
people, that kind of thing.
I think if you were with someone
that you didn't know very well,
you probably wouldn't want
to come across as chiding.
So you might want to just lead
by example, stay off your phone
if you can.
If you find that they're
using their phone a lot,
maybe just don't jump in
and start doing it yourself.
But if it's someone that
you know really well,
perhaps you could just-- if
this is resonating with you
and you feel like
there's some truth to it
and it's something you
want to carry forward,
you could always just tell
them what you've learned
or how you're thinking
and feeling about it,
and see if that influences
them to do things differently.
I do think-- I have noticed
for myself that if you engage
other people in a
conversation about it
and you increase their
awareness for themselves
about how maybe constantly
being on their phones
is impacting them, it's a
lot easier to sort of say
let's leave the house right
now and just like leave
our phones here.
Let's just actually put the
technology away completely
and just go.
And I think that a lot of people
are willing to get on that page
once their consciousness
is raised around it.
But it's very context-dependent.
Does that help?
OK.
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
modern loneliness kind of stuff,
do you have any data
or see any patterns
about like it's worse in cities
or in different situations,
or like other environments
people can put themselves
that are better or worse?
LESLIE CARR: That's a
really good question.
The data around that is
complicated I read something
recently that said
that people who
live in non-urban environments,
rural or-- I was about to say
rural or suburban, but they
may have been-- actually I do
think it was related to rural
and suburban environments.
They were saying that
people experience
greater degrees of
loneliness just because they
are physically separated
by other people
and not living, existing
with as much community.
But I also know that
there's a lot of research
that people who
live-- they've done
really fascinating
research, some of which
involves rats, that the more
people or animals or whatever
that you crowd into
a certain, space,
the more they avoid each
other and sort of create
a sense of psychological
distance that we theorize
is meant to kind of
buffer against some
of the physical distance
that's being impinged upon.
There actually is some
really interesting research
that has to do with
urban environments
showing that even though
you have a lot of people
who are physically there, they
tend to avoid one another more.
Anecdotally, we can
probably see this
in cities like New York City.
People are less likely
to know their neighbors
than, let's say, people who
live in a suburban environment,
because I think they
tend to buffer themselves
a little bit more.
So I think that we see different
things in different places.
But I think it probably has more
to do on an individual level
with people in the way they
are existing in the world
and relating to people
in their community,
whether it's suburban,
rural, or urban.
Does that answer your question?
It's complicated, I think.
I think it has more to do
with an individual person's
psychological makeup
than it has to do
with the density of the
population where they are.
Yeah.
In terms of whether
they feel lonely or not.
AUDIENCE: So what
about a situation at
work where I'm feeling
like in the zone
and I'm really
focused on something,
and then I have to go out
and maybe there's a client
or like I'm meeting
with my manager
and I need to be open and do
some of these active listening
skills.
If I'm in this
focused zone, it's
just not conducive maybe
for the active listening.
I don't know--
how can I do that?
What would be the way to go--
LESLIE CARR: It's
such a good question.
I've focused it through the
lens of almost gear shifting.
There are a couple of different
ways that you can do this.
I think if you even have
so much as a hallway
to walk down from computer
to business meeting, that
can sometimes be enough
time or space to create
a little bit of a
physical distance
where you can create a little
bit of an emotional pivot
of sorts.
It's kind of a matter of
stepping away from the computer
and giving yourself
the walk down
the hallway to just kind of
slough things off and shift
gears.
A lot of it is
intentional in my mind,
that if you create the
intention on that hallway
walk to shift gears and
to try to be more present,
you can even use the
walk-- for those of you
who are familiar with
different styles of meditation,
there are seated meditations
where we close our eyes
and do that kind of thing, and
there are walking meditations
where we just walk and focus
on the feeling of our feet
on the ground.
That's a little bit
more akin to the sort
of mindfulness-based
awareness exercise
that I brought us through
right in the beginning
of the talk, the
idea that you can
turn on this kind of awareness
anytime you want just by sort
of making a decision to do so.
So if you have the opportunity
to take a walk and just shift
gears, you can do it that way.
And if you don't
have the opportunity,
if you don't have that
hallway, I would just
say as you turn to
speak to someone
and they're starting
to talk to you,
just give yourself a moment
to just look them in the eye,
take a moment to even look
at the top of their head
if you don't want to be staring
at their eyeballs, and just
sort of ground
yourself a little bit.
Kind of do a little bit
of an attentional pivot.
Something to try out, maybe
you can see if it helps.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is basically
about the miscommunication
or misunderstanding.
As you mentioned,
different people
have different perspectives.
So maybe you said one
thing, your friend
understands differently.
And sometimes you could
create some hard feelings.
But you'd really like
to get this cleared,
you don't like to
[INAUDIBLE] this
between you and your friend.
So what would be the best way?
Because they just take
maybe the wrong way.
AUDIENCE: So that is
such a juicy question.
So just to recap,
I take it you're
saying if you have
a misunderstanding
with somebody--
you say something,
they take it the wrong
way, you didn't mean it,
let's say the way they
took it, but now you
have two people who are kind
of not seeing eye to eye,
how do you work it out.
This is a little bit
of an advanced skill,
but a really, really good one.
Going back to that idea of just
suspending judgement and really
honoring somebody's
subjectivity,
I think that one of the most
amazing gifts that we could
give ourselves or somebody
else is to understand that
it's not-- especially when it
comes to interpersonal conflict
or communication, it's
really not a matter at all
of who's right and who's wrong,
but taking two different people
who have two completely
different subjectivities about
something and understanding that
however it is that, let's say,
person B responded to
what person A said,
that it's not that
they're wrong--
they may have
misinterpreted something,
they didn't take it the
way person A intended it--
but to really divorce
things from who's right
and who's wrong and just try
to understand each person's
perspective.
Because, for example, the
reason why the second person
may have misinterpreted
what person A said
is because it triggered a
past memory of something.
Like you saying x, y or z to me
reminds me of something that's
old and now I feel upset
at you, it's not even
your fault, that kind of thing.
So just trying to understand
why the person took it
the wrong way and
then explaining that,
despite what that
person thought,
that you meant
something else, and just
honoring both person's
subjectivities usually
is I think probably the best
way to resolve a conflict,
rather than feeling
like but you're
wrong to have
interpreted it that way.
That's not what I
meant, therefore
you're wrong for
having interpreted
what I said in that manner.
But just sort of
saying like oh, I'm
so sorry, I didn't mean
to-- it wasn't my intention.
I think you heard
that in a way that was
different than what I meant.
But tell me what you're
thinking or feeling.
You know?
Does that help?
All right, good.
AUDIENCE: How could someone
who is a good active listener
effectively engage with
someone who is not?
LESLIE CARR: That's a good one.
That's a really good one.
And actually don't step
away for me, Rachel, yet,
just in case she
needs that mike back.
Because here's
what I'm wondering.
So I take it that you're
thinking of situations where
someone is doing a really
good job of listening
and the other person
is really kind
of running roughshod over them
and doing all of the talking.
The first thing that I
think of is potentially
maybe needing to interject
more than feels natural to you.
If you're the kind of person
who is often accustomed to being
in the listening role and
you're with someone who's
more than happy to kind of
keep talking and kind of take
advantage of the fact
that you're listening,
you may have to do
something that's quite a bit
different than what I've been
talking about today, which
is really summon the
gumption to kind of speak up
or to talk over someone,
or to maybe even at times
say excuse me, I was
speaking, I'm not done yet.
You know, to sort of assert
yourself a little bit more.
That in some ways
could be the topic
of a whole different speech, how
to assert yourself in that way.
But I guess I would say
that I don't think that
just because we've been talking
about the benefits of listening
today that it's always our
job to listen and never assert
ourselves or never try to be
the one who's speaking or having
an opinion or
expressing that opinion.
Everyone deserves a
chance to-- everyone
deserves a seat at the table.
So yes, I would not want
any of this material
to be misinterpreted
in that way.
But it might be time
just to speak up
for yourself a little bit more
with whoever that person is.
AUDIENCE: So I find that as a
recently new parent that some
of the most complex
relationships
I have are within my family,
and sometimes even with my kids.
What does it look
like to sort of get
on the same page with
your kids by doing
this sort of active listening?
Rather than saying no, you're
not supposed to do that,
to really make them feel
heard and to figure out
some common ground so that you
can move them towards a place
where they kind of
are behaving in a way
you think is appropriate
without kind of judging them.
LESLIE CARR: That's
a good question.
How old are your kids?
AUDIENCE: One and
two and a half.
But they grow fast.
LESLIE CARR: Yes, they do.
Yes they do.
And you're planning ahead.
I like it.
So I am not a parent, and
I'm not a parenting expert.
But I'll tell you
what I think of when
I think about that question.
There are two things
primarily that come to mind.
One is that you do,
for better or worse,
as a parent have
to be the parent.
You're going to have
to sometimes tell them
that it's bedtime or tell them
that they need to do something
that they may not want to do.
And I don't necessarily
feel like a parent has
to be a perfect active
listener, let's say,
with a toddler who's
throwing a tantrum.
But I think where
these skills could
be particularly
useful in parenting,
and especially parenting
any child who's
getting to be old enough
to express an opinion
or whatever, is just to,
in certain circumstances,
honor the fact that
that kid is actually
responding to something.
I think one of the
biggest problems
that we have nationally-speaking
when I look--
and this gets more
into issues related
to mental health, mental illness
sort of on a national scale.
Something that I think is a real
shame is that a lot of times
when kids are let's say acting
out, like behavior that's
traditionally considered
to be acting out,
a lot of times that kid is
just going through something
and the adults, the parents
around them, their teachers,
are more concerned
with getting the kid
to behave than trying to figure
out what it is that's going on.
So as your kids start to
get a little bit older,
I wouldn't
necessarily apply this
to the tantrum that happens
in the grocery store aisle
because they really want the
fruit roll-ups or something.
But if you start to realize,
especially if you're
starting to see a
pattern around a way
that a kid is
responding-- let's say
they're starting
to kind of act out
or they're becoming a little
bit problematic in some way--
getting super curious what
is happening with this kid
right now, and what is
he or she responding to,
and how can I maybe honor
his or her subjectivity
and just get really
curious about what's
happening rather than
just trying to get them
to do what I want them to do.
There are going to
be times when you're
going to have to do that.
You're just going to
have to be parental.
And knowing when to do
each of those things
is where things get maybe
a little bit more nuanced.
But I do think there's a lot
to be said for getting curious
about why kids are acting
the way that they do
and trying to figure it out
as opposed to just trying
to make it stop.
AUDIENCE: All right, so when
we have issues or are talking
to other people and
we're triggered,
there's like a
conflict or you don't
want to speak to someone
specifically, how much of that
is from my own experience, from
what my history is and maybe
my family, versus like the
actual moment in me speaking
with that person?
Is it both of those things?
Is it like--
LESLIE CARR: Will you
say that one more time?
I'm not sure if I understand it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So if I'm in a conversation
with someone, engaged
in a conversation, and
I'm just triggered,
like something lights up and I'm
all of a sudden annoyed or like
wow, how could they say
that, or have a reaction,
I'm wondering in the
moment how much of that
is from something in my
past versus in the moment.
LESLIE CARR: That is
super context-dependent,
and I think varies
really depending
on what the circumstances are.
I think that we have
moments all the time
where we feel triggered
by something that somebody
said to us because that
person is being an asshole,
you know, and then sometimes
when we're feeling triggered
by something because it's
activating something deeply
personal for us and
maybe we're overreacting
a little bit because
something is getting
triggered that's deeper.
That is-- it would be very hard
to come up with a ratio that's
attached to that
that is generalizable
all across the board,
because I think
it's so unique to every
single individual moment
that people live through.
But I think even just being
aware of the fact that it
happens is something, you know,
knowing that it's not always
what's happening in
the moment is sometimes
triggering something
historical, that's good to know.
RACHEL AMERA: Dr. Carr, thank
you for coming in today.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks.
LESLIE CARR: Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]